world
for me my experience with it was I
thought it was a pretty Perfect film oh
I liked it a lot the first time I
honestly liked it more this time like I
was saying yesterday it felt a little
long okay
surprises that I wasn't expecting
um a lot of really great actions I don't
think there was any other way that they
could have handled it more Tastefully in
a way that was meaningful you know and
helpful for you know fans of Chadwell
Postman yeah so I thought it was
powerful I think that everything the
casting crew wanted to execute in terms
of communicating
um their pain and their
Journey
with losing Chadwick I think they
executed that I'm sure it's all been
said already the widest guy go first
that's right people want to hear my
opinion
what's interesting is that
it's it's almost not acting it's it's
real these these people were mourning
the loss of Chadwick Boseman their their
friend so in a way like this amazing
acting that we see every single actor
did an incredible job it's it's real
it's like real raw emotions captured on
film which is just
beautiful and sad at the same time it's
a very emotional film incredibly
emotional
all right so I just got out of the
theater watching black panther wakanda
forever
poster right there
um
I'm so overwhelmed with emotion and I
don't even know how I feel right now so
I'm gonna ask a bunch of other creators
how they feel as we're all coming out
here
and give you kind of a YouTuber reaction
to everything Brandon Davis here.com PCR
podcast awesome dude your second time
what were your thoughts first time in
this time
um I'd like to go out the first time I
honestly liked it more this time like I
was saying yesterday it felt a little
long okay flew by yeah
like I was able to kind of just back and
appreciate it because the first time I
watched it I was really kind of focused
on Chadwick yeah
do you feel his absence in the movie and
the second time around like I was able
to just focus on the characters that are
that are there contributes to him are
great and they're out there in the whole
movie yeah and honestly like the
characters like the performance isn't
this one Angela Bassett
uh
like and uh tonight is oh gosh the new
Marvel favorite for sure yeah actually
gets to really do some stuff like really
do some stuff and the performance is
great a cold here
[Music]
follow them
God doesn't know who we are
you just take over party
we'll start with the job oh my goodness
I mean I'm sure it's all been set up the
widest guy go first that's right people
want to hear my opinion
[Music]
hey uh am I doing this wow
I really enjoyed the movie I thought I
had a lot of moving elements to it as
far as like you really felt the loss of
Chadwick while watching this movie and
there was a lot of action it was a lot
funnier than I expected it to be uh I
think that overall you do feel
before the course of the movie there's a
lot of really good surprises a lot of
very powerful moments I think has one of
the most moving post-credits scenes of
any Marvel movie that we've seen in the
last 12 years
I would agree it got me the ending and
the post credit got man
all right thank you Aaron we're gonna
ignore John no yeah great go no I don't
want to do that oh my God
you look like
I get a second opinion
take mine as well anyways
um
yeah I
I almost don't want to talk with anyone
about it to be honest because I thought
it was uh
for me my experience with it was I
thought it was a pretty Perfect film
like other than the only thing I'd say
is like there's a couple of moments
where you're like yeah that CGI looks a
little awful what movie doesn't have
that mission the Apple every movie yes
are you talking about like at the end
fight
yeah I think I know what you're talking
about yeah a little bit like
I thought it was the most moving MCU
movie ever and it quickly it's just my
cup of tea it's it's so it's so
emotional but also bad at it's like it's
a movie about grief but it's also so
badass at the same time like I don't
know I did it but you did it and then I
uh yeah it was I thought the acting was
phenomenal I think I think it's probably
the best acting out of any Marvel movie
come on I think I can I can't think of
an MCA movie where the acting isn't this
good I think Angela Bassett deserves
Oscar consideration for a workout
true that step out of the way guys let
me handle it I know Martin Freeman not
enough ever Ross okay I had nothing to
relate to no I think this does a really
beautiful job of taking the real life
grief and then infusing it with a
geopolitical war movie that does
complement the you know tone and style
of the first film but very much uh
Blends the personal and the overarching
huge action Stakes like it's it's a
perfect blend of both and it really is a
movie about watching a bunch of people
process and come to terms with grief uh
yeah in a surprisingly you know still
Marvel movie package that finds a great
balance between the two it's got yeah
much more of that really weighty heavy
drama than you'd expect from a normal
MCU movie but it has all the Thrills and
all the excitement that you would want
so that it doesn't feel like a totally
somber experience on top of that so yeah
I couldn't compliment it enough earlier
throughout the film it's not like oh
let's have a sad thing in the beginning
and and it obviously comes up for our
video Jesus
white guys gotta stick together
all right now I'm here with the lovely
achara hello what did you think I really
really enjoyed it uh it was incredibly
moving I tried a fair [ __ ]
and I laughed I shared there was
definitely surprises that I wasn't
expecting
um a lot of really great action like
they put it together in such a way where
it felt like a fishing tribute to black
panther to Coachella to chat with
Bozeman while still kind of being in its
own movie and moving on in a really easy
way I like how you put that like it's
still being its own movie that it really
is yeah and but but at the same time
they do great job entering honoring
chadway yeah
it is quite moving in many different
ways yeah it's super fun very very it is
a really fun movie I don't think people
are going to walk out of this movie
going I don't know if people can say it
sucks no yeah I don't really yeah I
don't think so I mean it's definitely
different from Black Panther because
when that movie came out I think it's
just a lot of us by surprise and it was
just so different and so it set the
template and this one Carries On from
that but obviously like you know the
world without the characters now we just
get more of an opportunity to spend time
with them which is great so yeah I
really really enjoyed it awesome thank
you and you bought her on Japanese
Channel as well we'll put that down
below we're here with Chevy a lot of
people know him because I know they've
mentioned him many times in my channel
not here with Grace Greg's over there
and uh your thoughts I really liked it a
lot um I felt like for two hours and 40
minutes for me the movie moved along in
a way that I didn't feel the pace I
think that out for it being a follow-up
film without Chadwick Boseman it
actually held its own really really well
yeah so that was a big concern going in
like yeah where we really feel the
absence of chadway did you feel the
absence didn't hold it back
um I mean nothing could be done about
that I think their handling a bit was
the best that could be expected like I
don't I don't think there was any other
way that they could have handled it more
Tastefully in a way that was meaningful
you know and helpful for you know fans
of Chadwell Postman yeah so I thought it
was powerful they did handle yeah
I really think like you said they kind
of did the best they could yeah with
what they had yeah all right but I have
no complaints with regards to how they
handle that at all I have complaints but
I'm not gonna talk about them here next
one you have to watch it on his channel
they're minor but like overall I really
enjoyed this film it's awesome yeah oh
be sure to follow Javi I'll put
everyone's links down below okay thanks
all right now we got my man e-man it's
his second time seen it as well because
it was at the premiere last night
um humans
you started the recast t'challa movement
yeah so I know this movie was very
important to you yes going in so you've
seen it twice now it sucks wow
um so keeping this boiler free
um
that's still very emotional
um
I think that everything the casting crew
wanted to execute in terms of
communicating
um their pain and their
Journey
with losing Chadwick I think they
executed that
um I am still conflicted uh emotionally
and a lot of that has to do with
fusing
real life trauma into fiction
um because normally you know look let's
say Tony Stark right Tony Stark guys
spoiler alert sorry you know come on you
don't feel as conflicted emotionally
because Robert Downey is fine right but
the fact that like every time they would
have a line about the challah it sounded
like they were talking about chadway so
I just think that you know depending on
your level of attachment to Chadwick or
t'challa or the franchise
um that's going to determine how hard
this is gonna hit you or not
um so that's why I tell people like look
I I feel the way I feel because I've
been incredibly attached to this I mean
um to travel was my favorite superhero
uh Chadwick was one of my favorite
actors
um so I'm clearly going to be more
sensitive about certain things when they
happen
um but at the same time I totally
understand how it's still a process you
know for people to go through as grief
is
um you know everyone doesn't go through
grief the same way
um
I will say that if the the awkwardness
the uncomfortability that I kind of went
through was the fact that like when
Chadwick passed I cried I balled out
like it it hurts you know and I had my
two years to kind of like deal with it
and then coming back to the movie
I mean those type of wounds don't really
close but it was like poking right back
at it yeah just reopening it a little
bit so I was just like ah like again you
know some scenes in there where I was
like oh here it comes yeah you're like
you know exactly what's about to happen
and you're like yep right just bring it
on right you know
um but I will say that
um despite any creative differences I
might have disagreed with
um I still
and appreciative of the fact that they
tried to find some common ground
um so my my impression right now is
there's a lot of leg work that needs to
be done with the ending so whatever they
have with the ending I'm not trying to
spoil it
they better build the hell out of that
that's that's where I'm at with it right
so
um
yeah that's I'm I'm opal optimistic
and I'm gonna keep my eye on
what happens in the future I I'm I think
I'm with you on that I'm like okay I see
what you're doing yeah now do it yes
that's it so as you can see
I really didn't know how I felt coming
out of the theater there are some
absolutely incredible scenes in this
movie Namor is
fantastic one of the best MCU villains
ever like ever up there like really top
top three top five something he's he's
just up there amazing and the cast is
incredible everyone's performance is
incredible
I I truly did enjoy this movie I don't
think anyone's gonna say it sucked I did
feel the absence of
Chadwick and t'challa right I felt the
absence and
I'm trying to get around that
I think that's my biggest curve right
now with this movie and and make no
mistake this is the best movie they
could have made
with the circumstances they were put in
with losing Chadwick Boseman
since that happened this is the best
movie they could have made it is but I
couldn't help but to notice
his absence but as you can tell from
these creators reactions and slash my
personal friends
um some think it's perfect some think
it's great some think it's good I don't
think anyone's gonna walk away not at
least thinking this movie is good but
again to me I just I I felt that whole
but make no mistake the scenes that we
see the action that we see the acting
that we see is fantastic it's on another
level and it really is
the best they could have done and I
can't wait for everybody to see it and
let me know what they thought about it
as well and leave your thoughts about
all these reactions in the comments down
below and how excited you are to finally
see black panther what kind of forever
and I'll catch you all next time thank
you so much for watching wolf wolf